you know me gotta be thematic leather
jacket because Wolverine wears one you
know what else Wolverine has claws
the Wolverine butter knife claws do
still look better than the ones in x-men
origins Wolverine
so the Wolverine stars Wolverine played
by Hugh Jackman if you don't know who
bull Vereen is that's weird but I'll
explain it he's Wolverine you know the
x-men character he's still played by
Hugh Jackman he's still a badass now he
has his own standalone movie the first
one ever because another one never ever
happened ever all right it happened but
I'm gonna stop talking about that but
this is a new adventure and they're
really taking this one seriously they're
like okay we will make this one right
and of the x-men ish movies this is the
newest one if you line them all up
chronologically speaking this is the
newest one it takes place after x-men 3
and Wolverines in Japan because back
when Nagasaki got wasted in world war ii
he saved the guy's life and now that guy
he's an old guy and he's a somebody this
dude is rich as hell and before he dies
he wants to give Wolverine a chance to
will die really that's what Wolverine
wants he's like you know I know I get it
a long life it can be a curse I can take
away your mutant power so you don't heal
anymore and you can just go ahead and
live a normal life and die happy through
a series of circumstances this ends up
happening the Wolverine now Wolverine is
mortal it still has adamantium which I'm
sure would just render him useless on
the grounds he's like I can't move
because the adamantium is too heavy but
we suspend disbelief because this is the
x-men universe and we're supposed to and
I can do that if the movies actually
good is it good it's actually pretty
cool I really dug this movie first of
all I Shaq man still kicks asses
Wolverine when Hugh Jackman officially
becomes too old to be Wolverine I'm
gonna cry a little inside and a lot
outside it'll be a sad day but for now
he's still Wolverine and he will be for
years to come as far as I'm concerned
the premise is really cool - it's cool
to see Wolverine just be at it he's at
his lowest low here he has seen a lot of
death and destruction people have died
because of him people have died that he
cares about so he's just like I wanted
to end can it ends and now he hasn't out
now it can end but in that in that
situational circumstance he's a soldier
so he's like I still got to keep
fighting it's just a cool story arc for
Wolverine it's what I wanted out of this
movie it's what I got out of this movie
and there's a cool romance that builds
with Wolverine in this one chick and
there's somehow
chicks in this movie there are some hot
chicks in this movie some good some evil
vipers pretty hot though that's just I'm
just being real the action sequences
were pretty cool like some of them were
awesome and some I was like alright
shaky-cam
stop it the scene on the train you know
when they're on top of the Train and
they're fighting and they're jumping in
the trailer I was like that's going to
be the cheesiest part of the movie it
was actually the coolest action sequence
in the entire movie this was for me I
thought it was awesome it was just
really intense and it was really fast
and when things got hit people people
got hit hard but when people are running
from other people and they're shooting
at people and Wolverine slicing people
while they're running of course the
camera people are running holding the
cameras or the like yeah perfect Hugh
Jackman do it there weren't a lot of
shaky cam scenes in the movie but the
couple scenes that were shaky cam they
stand out in my mind and I'm like it's
definitely points off the movie was a
bit predictable at a point I was like
okay this is what's gonna happen at the
end here and it all right that's what's
happening right now you know what I do
hate though bone claws I I don't like
them I don't like Bhonsle I don't like
Wolverine having bone claws I know it's
all x-men comic book lore and he has
bone claws in the comic books also at a
point I didn't like it then either you
know in x2 and strikers like you were an
animal then you're an animal now I just
gave you claws bone claws kind of make
it like well no you didn't I already
already had them it's less efficient
versions of them but I they were around
I don't like grade-b claws made out of
bone that's just me that's my preference
though but is it fun I feel philosophy I
enjoyed the living [ __ ] out of this
movie this is the Wolverine if you're a
Wolverine fan this do it and if you're
an x-men fan in general also do it and
if you're a fan of movies that are cool
and enjoyable and you want to see a cool
summer movie also do it this was a solid
attempt at giving Wolverine his own
story his own movie and at first you're
like yeah he already got his own movie
and now they're doing it again but this
is like the legit shot at it so it
doesn't feel like overload you're like
okay you walk out of this movie going
well that's what I wanted the first time
around I will say I will definitely buy
the Wolverine on blu-ray
halfway through the credits this movie
does have a pretty cool extra scene in
it so stick around for that
right so the Wolverine have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you